pour parler du pass sanitaires pour le
parler de l'extension du pass sanitaire
nous sommes avec a dit que la landi
coordinateur du collectif parents
atterré kevin bossuet professeur
d'histoire en seine saint denis bonsoir
à vous deux merci d'être avec nous sur
rt france
alors première question pour kevin
bossuet hameau tout d'abord on vient de
le voir le projet de loi de passer du
pass sanitaire arrive à l'assemblée
l'examen du texte à commencer en
commission aujourd'hui vote des députés
demain projet qui prévoit l'obligation
vaccinale pour les soignants et
l'extension du passani terre dans les
gestes de la vie quotidienne des
français c'était indispensable
oui c'est indispensable mais la vérité
c'est que le gouvernement mac manque
considérablement de courage politique
parce que ce qu'il aurait fallu faire
évidemment c'est la vaccination
obligatoire pas seulement des soignants
mais la vaccination obligatoire de tout
le monde parce qu'on comprend bien
qu'ici en refusant finalement cette
vaccination obligatoire il a créé il a
créé ce pass senneterre évidemment qui
est concrètement qui n'est pas
applicable sur le terrain mettez vous à
la place des restaurateurs qui vont
devoir finalement se substituer à des
agents de police pour contrôler et qui
en tout qui n'entrent pas notamment dans
leurs établissements qui vont devoir
vérifier si la personne est vaccinée ou
pas donc il ya évidemment tout ce qui
est a trait au secret médical donc ça
pose de sérieuses questions et moi
j'étais cet après midi notamment avec
des restaurateurs qui me disaient mais
moi comment voulez vous que je fasse
pour contrôler ce pas sanitaires à
partir du moment où il y à un client
qu'il va monter le ton je vais pas
monter le ton également je vais le
laisser passer parce que j'ai pas envie
de classe j'ai pas envie de me faire
taper dessus donc je pense qu'il ya un
manque de responsabilité du gouvernement
un manque de courage politique il faut
dès aujourd'hui une obligation vaccinale
pour tous parce que c'est comme ça que
nous ne sortirons de cette crise et
épidémiques nicolas landi de votre côté
vous êtes d'accord avec ce texte face au
courant d'un virus qui menace une
quatrième vague avec le vent le delta on
y est d'ailleurs le porte parole du
gouvernement a parlé de cette quatrième
vague il faut obliger aux contraintes au
maximum les français à se faire vacciner
je pense que s'ils continuent à penser
que la vaccination contre le coronavirus
doit être la décision de chacun
et que c'est une décision personnelle
parce que deux choses l'une où le vaccin
est efficace ce qui est vraisemblable et
à ce moment là les personnes qui sont
vaccinées ne court pas de risque et ceux
qui ne sont pas vaccinés ne vont pas
courir de risques aux personnes qui le
sont ou alors le vaccin n'est pas
efficace et à ce moment là pourquoi le
rendre obligatoire
donc voilà une position qui me semble
aussi raisonnable mais je tiens à dire
qu'il faut respecter les analyses et
interprétations des opinions de chacun
et ça je pense que c'est un postulat
très important surtout en ce moment
parce que la manière dans cette
vaccination obligatoire est en train
d'être mise en place
avec ce pass sanitaire abouti à monter
les gens les uns contre les autres des
parties des populations contre les
autres considèrent que tout d'un coup
elles sont mises en danger par des gens
qui serait irresponsable et je pense que
ça c'est extrêmement dangereux alors le
projet de loi entame à son aile son
parcours parlementaire puisque les
députés vont débattre autour de ce
projet de loi est pas mal vont voter nos
kevin bossuet un texte qui interpelle
puisque les opposants politiques parlent
elles de projets de lois liberticides se
passe sanitaire est ce que c'est un
recul de la liberté
non mais je crois qu'il faut arrêter
d'exagérer et on est en pleine hystérie
collective moi j'ai vu en cours de ces
derniers jours des gens comparent et le
pas salutaire à l'étoile jaune des gens
comparer la campagne de vaccination à la
choix des gens comparent emmanuel macron
à hitler et des gens finalement s'en
prendre à des députés en les menaçant de
mort ou encore brûlé des centres de
vaccination je peux comprendre qu'on est
évidemment des doutes à l'encontre du
vaccin c'est naturel moi même je me suis
fait vacciner j'y suis pas allé en
courant évidemment j'ai pesé le pour et
le contre mais à un moment donné quand
on a l'intérêt général chevillée au
corps je crois que la seule chose qu'il
est possible de faire c'est se faire
vacciner soit on ne sortira pas de cette
crise sanitaire soit on va en sortir
collectivement qui tout ce débat sur les
libertés
il faut un petit peu arrêter je veux
dire on dit en société dans une société
il ya évidemment des règles et ces
règles
sont légitimes à partir du moment où
l'intérêt national l'affairé connectique
l'emportent finalement sur l'intérêt
individuel donc il est bien évident que
se faire vacciner c'est un geste citoyen
se faire vacciner ce a permis de
développer de d'éviter de développer des
formes graves et d'engorger les centres
hospitaliers et ça permet surtout
d'éviter de transmettre le virus parce
que je le rappelle en effet quelqu'un
qui est vaccinée à 12 fois moins de
chances de transmettre le virus
un peu de responsabilité sortons ces
manipulations politiques de ces
manipulations historique essayé nous
concentrer sur l'intérêt général il
colle alors dit vous partager la même
analyse pardon moi ce que je me
souhaiterait surtout c'est qu'on sorte
de cette hystérisation on a depuis le
début de cette crise une communication
extrêmement anxiogène et on a fait peur
à tout le monde
et du coup on en arrive à cette
crispation et on fait qu' on ne s'écoute
plus et je pense que les décisions qui
sont prises aujourd'hui ne sont pas les
bonnes
moi je représente un collectif de
parents donc de parents d'enfants
aujourd'hui parmi tous ces parents vous
avez à peu près 50% qui n'a pas pu se
faire vacciner et même parmi ces gens
beaucoup de gens qui veulent se faire
vacciner et ils vont partir en vacances
dans dix jours avec leurs enfants ils
n'auront pas leur parcours vaccinale
complet bon alors qu'ils n'ont pas fait
vacciner du tout et ils vont s'ils
arrivent sur leur lieu de vacances parce
qu'ils n'auront plus le droit de prendre
le train ils vont arriver sur les lieux
ils ont peut-être plus le droit
d'accéder et ils vont vouloir faire des
activités auxquelles nous n'auront plus
accès ils en seront privés
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont expliquer à leurs
enfants est ce que on avait une telle
urgence
on doit avoir effectivement créé des
citoyens qui ont tous leurs droits d'un
côté et d'autres qui ne les ont plus au
moins temporairement
je pense que ce n'est pas une bonne
chose et ce n'est pas non plus la
société qu'on veut montrer ou expliquer
à nos enfants
alors on arrive justement à cette
question concernant elle et les écoles
la question du pass sanitaires pour les
écoles et les
versité à la rentrée se pose on sait que
les écoles sont des lieux où le virus se
transmet facilement vous êtes pour le
pass annie terre au collège par exemple
kevin bossuet alors donc je ne suis pas
pour le pass sanitaire au collège
puisque je considère que l'éducation est
un droit et je n'aimerais pas finalement
compris dans les enfants d'aider des
parents qui ne sont pas vaccinés ou qui
refusent de faire vacciner leurs enfants
enfin je ne joue pas tous les enfants
ont le droit à une éducation donc le
pass and i ter n'est pas une fin en soi
le passé l'inter c'est un moyen c'est un
moyen d'inciter les gens à se faire
vacciner c'est un moyen en effet
d'éviter que le virus se propage mais il
ne faut pas non plus aller trop loin
parce que si on va trop loin en effet on
risque de remettre en cause certains
droits fondamentaux on risque surtout de
braquer des gens et de braquer la
société c'est pour ça qu'il faut aller
progressivement vers une vaccination
obligatoire de tous les français et plus
particulièrement des enseignants vous
savez moi je suis fonctionnaire je me
suis fait vacciner tout simplement parce
que je pense que j'ai un devoir
d'exemplarité en tant que fonctionnaire
d'état je dois montrer l'exemple aux
autres je dois être une forme de modèle
est montré en effet aux parents
finalement que c'est la vaccination qui
va nous permettre de sortir de ces
crises donc un moment un peu de
responsabilité un moment essayons
d'éviter de tomber dans les bêtises que
l'on voit fleurir au cours de ces
derniers jours et vaccinons nous parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on sortira de
cette crise encore une fois ceux qui
ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord avec ce
discours là finalement ne prennent pas
conscience qu'ils sont en train de jouer
sur la peur et qui est tout cela va
déboucher soit sur un niveau confinement
ou soit vers une sortie de crise qui va
être excessivement tardive avec les
conséquences sociales et économiques que
l'on veut entrevoir au cours des
prochaines semaines et des prochains
mois alors nicolas landry je m'appelle
que vous êtes coordinateur du collectif
par atterré un enfant de onze ans qui
sera en 6e qu'est-ce qui va se voir
qu'est ce qui va se passer pour lui à la
rentrée j'espère qu'on va conditionner
son accès à l'école
la vaccination comment la conditionner
l'accès à l'école des enfants au port du
masque est huit à dix heures par jour
depuis un an maintenant et pour les plus
petits de 6 à 11 ans l'école primaire à
partir du mois de novembre
les enfants n'ont pas eu le droit par l'
approche bénéfice risque quand on nous
parle tellement aujourd'hui avec cette
vaccination obligatoire et chaud ça très
dommage
il a reconduit énormément d'études avec
des éléments objectifs étayé et ça n'a
pas été retenu on nous a même écrit que
l'urgence de lutter contre le colis
était tellement importante qu'on n'avait
pas le temps de mener une étude coût
avantage sur la palme du masque sur les
jeunes enfants pour vous voyez je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup d'empressement
il ya deux poids deux mesures et sans
utiliser du tout les termes de notre
invité moi je propose qu'on travaille je
propose qu'on avance ensemble et qu'on
pas vraiment les bénéfices risques de
tous ses moyens qu'on a aujourd'hui de
lutter contre une pandémie pour ne
conteste pas mais juste ajouter quelque
chose
j'ai eu la chance d'être élu local
pendant huit ans vice président de le
mans métropole
aujourd'hui je suis dirigeant
d'entreprise j'ai pas vraiment le profil
du complotistes mes enfants sont
vaccinés
d'accord pas qu'on peut le comique mais
contre toutes les maladies contre
lesquelles il fallait être là qu signer
parce que ils sont en danger grâce ils
ne le sont pas donc ne caricaturons pas
travaillons ensemble avance on en
sortira ainsi effectivement mais pour
moi c'est ça la première solidarité
nationale n'oublions pas que les droits
les libertés
ça peut faire aussi partie du solde du
compte quand on fera les comptes du
président
on verra que ça aussi a eu des pertes
comme des pertes au niveau social
comme j'ai eu de la misère qui s'est
déclenchée qui s'est développée et je ne
suis pas sûr que le passé ni terre et
l'obligation à chaque vaccinale soit la
solution
dernier axe de ce débat très rapidement
vraiment mais sur ce une enquête récente
de l'ifop trois quarts des français
pensent que le pass à lithaire va créer
des inégalités entre les français
vaccinés et ceux qui ne sont pas est-ce
que
parce sanitaire c'est une fracture qui
se créent dans la société ce que ça
finalement créer encore plus
d'inégalités kevin mensuel il est
évident que ça crée des fractures voyez
bien au cours de ces derniers jours
qu'il ya deux camps qui sont en train de
se constituer avec d'un côté en effet
les gens qui ne sont pas vaccinés qui
revendique finalement leur libre arbitre
à leur liberté de ne pas se faire
vacciner piscine allemands de l'autre
finalement les vaccinés qui disent qu'il
faut la jouer collectif et que les ce
qu'ils refusent de vacciner en effet
sont irresponsables et on va vers une
fracture de la société quand vous
regardez les enquêtes d'opinion je vous
voyais que finalement cette fracture est
aussi une fracture intergénérationnel
puisque les plus jeunes en effet ce sont
sont plus rétifs à se faire vacciner a
accepté ces mesures alors que finalement
les plus anciens se sont davantage
d'accords avec les mesures qui sont
prises par emmanuel macron c'est pour ça
qu'il faut avancer dans la vaccination
il faut faire en sorte que ces périodes
de division en effet n'est pas des
conséquences trop dévastatrices parce
qu'une fois que la crise sera derrière
nous il va falloir évidemment
reconstruire et en effet ça va être en
effet compliqué on est déjà dans une
société avec une fracture identitaire
une fracture économique une fracture
sociale ce qu'ils ont sur ajoute en
effet la fracture des vaccinés des noms
matinée je pense en effet qu'on ne va
jamais s'en sortir vaccinons nous pour
qu'on sorte de cette crise le plus
rapidement possible et que les
conséquences ne soit pas le soin les
plus réduite possible très rapidement
nicolas landi les français ont raison de
se mobiliser
je met un peu je vais être un peu il
peut de place
moi j'aurais tout prendre préféré une
véritable obligation vaccinale c'est à
dire si vous vacciner pas eh bien vous
avez une sanction financière
au moins ça aura été clair et ça
n'aurait pas fracturé la société
française et je pense que voilà ça donne
bien l'opinion d'une bonne partie des
parents
ses parents ce qui se passe en ce moment
la manière et la brutalité dont on mène
ce combat pour la vaccination qui peut
être entendent à bhl qui peuvent être
légitimes
elle n'est pas la bonne merci beaucoup
merci à vous d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur l'extension du pass
sanitaires à cali de monsieur je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur
d'histoire et les colorants dit je
rappelle que notre coordinateur du
collectif parents à terre